what's that my group chats all we were
talking about was how incredible LeBron
was and we see him here but I want that
graphic year 21 LeBron and what he's
doing and Vince I promise you this is
not try to diminish your year 21 but
when you compare what LeBron is doing at
this part of his career to guys like
Vince and Robert Parish it is staggering
to see what I mean Vince I just want you
to take us in like you're second on that
list how did you feel when in your year
21 and let to think about what he's
doing now I mean I know how I felt and I
know what it took to get
to to be able to play night in and night
out I mean he's still a go-to guy he's
very like I said he's still dominated
right and that's just a testament to
what he's who he is and his commitment
to his body and his game I mean he's a
special talent we we've known that since
day one but I tell you
what he's playing like I mean it's if
you didn't know he was in year 20
whatever you wouldn't you like you like
oh okay well because like I find Vince I
find you to be one of the most athletic
players that has ever been in the NBA
and I can even see on your face right
now that this is confusing to you well
no I I mean to to an extent because like
I I
know I know how I felt some nights gr we
talk and I I always wonder but I tell
you what he just he takes in the stride
and he knows how to turn it on and you
you when you're playing when you play
that long you learn how win and when not
to if you when to tail it back when to
turn it up when not to and and I think
Anthony Davis is extremely important to
LeBron success like we said because he's
going to need him to step into the
Forefront sometimes and yes he did it in
the inseason tournament but I think
throughout the the course of the Year
Anthony David plays a huge role for
LeBron being successful in the playoffs
well you know it's interesting Vince
says that look I played 19 years Vince
played 21 as you get older you become
more efficient you you're not doing the
athletic things as much what I saw him
beating everybody down the floor like
he's still doing hard athletic thing
he's not beating you with threes and
efficient one dribble pullup he's
getting downhill being physical which in
year 21 with all that Miles I mean his
his greatest ability we people have said
this before his greatest ability might
be his availability but avail ility at a
high level over multiple decades quick
but that says to me that he does the
work after games that's why I was going
to say the drive to continue to want to
chase that great he's still getting
haircuts on game days so that means he's
still excited to come to the arena he's
still excited to put on shows the drive
is still there and it's unbelievable you
got to be fresh you got to be fresh you
know you guys both got your haircut
today so wait so you're telling me if
they don't get a haircut they really
don't care no I'm just saying no cuz
this is interesting listen when you're a
rookie right and you're going to LA or
you're going we all know when your first
time going you want to look sharp you
want the haircut he's still doing that
in year 21 so he's still like feeling
like a kid while he's out there he wins
The Champ wi to his world that was great
and then he goes and watch his son at
USC which is incredible